high-speed chase involving a stolen
police cruiser in Ohio led to a series
of crashes ending with the death of two
children this was the scene in downtown
Dayton last night this is the last thing
Dayton needs police say a man reportedly
stabbed a woman then led police on a
wild chase ten other people were hurt
mark Strassmann is here mark how on
earth did the suspect managed to steal a
police car
well good morning for starters witnesses
say it appears the suspect was
intoxicated police say he crashed his
truck after driving away from the side
of the stabbing but when he crashed he
jumped into a police cruiser somehow
responding to the scene and the deadly
drive continues cell phone video shows a
Riverside police officer attempting to
arrest a stabbing suspect he manages to
climb into the driver's seat of the
police cruiser the officer tased the man
who was trying to get away
John Poston shot this video and watched
the chaotic scene unfold the officer
tased him at point-blank range and the
guy still ended up getting in the
driver's seat driving it backwards up
the street turning a corner with it and
there he drove into the other police
officer the suspect barreled through
busy streets of downtown Dayton leaving
behind a path of mangled cars before
crashing into a pole outside the Dayton
metro library just like that the suspect
crashed into at least three vehicles one
was a van carrying seven children person
one screamed kids are in a car and
to do my best to try to get as many of
the kids out of the bed as I could des
Norris hope good says the van seats
pinned some of the children inside it
was something that I can't really
describe it was difficult to see what
was inside the van see the kids in a
condition that they were at least 12
people were taken to hospitals some in
critical condition I really didn't know
what to do but hold my kids and give
them the biggest hug afterwards just
it's just seeing something like that
just shows you that anything happened in
a split second police haven't identified
the suspect he was also hurt in the
chase Tony that was hospitalized Marc
thank you